pop
[Musique]
pour les
pouvez vous nous dire comment devient
ton femme arbitre il faut passer un
examen pratique un examen théorique et
après ça si on a satisfait aux
conditions l'aïe on est arbitre on a
parlé de vocation pour vous aimez
vraiment beaucoup le football
oui vous avez déjà joué oui avec des
garçons des gosses de la rue dit alors
comment vous est venu là la vocation
pour l'arbitrage mais c'était la seule
manière de participer aux jeux alors
juste un arbitre est-ce que c'est pas
gênant pour vous diriger des hommes sur
un terrain est-ce qui vous obéissent
bien oui bien sûr il se laisse toujours
cette façon l'arbitré seul maître sur le
terrain oui bien sur ma faim est ce
qu'il n'ya pas des fois et des
contestations est ce que vous savez
garder votre sang froid
mais jusqu'à présent ce tout s'est très
bien passé je pense que ça continuera
comme ça c'est pas donc trop gênant pour
vous voulez notre pain timide et quand
vous pénétrez sur un terrain non pas du
tout à votre avis est-ce que vous pensez
que c'est vraiment la place d'une jeune
fille de faire ce de s'adonner à cette
activité
non c'est pas assez pas précisément la
place d'une jeune film vu que les femmes
prennent de plus en plus d'importance
dans le monde moderne puis y avoir des
femmes arbitres
comment êtes-vous dans la viscose oeil
bon caractère est ce que vous êtes
autoritaire france il faut quand même
avoir un peu de caractère pour faire
celui ci oui quand je veux quelque chose
en général jusqu'au bout pour l'avoir
qu'il âge avez-vous 18 ans et vous
comptez l'arbitré encore longtemps
oui bien sûr le plus longtemps possible
vous espérez vous marier un jour et vous
pensez que si vous étiez marié vous
arbitres y est quand même oui pourquoi
pas oui après tout pourquoi pas que
pensent les jeunes filles de votre âge
aux amis affrontera trouve ça ridicule
ça s'est jamais vu qui est des femmes
arbitres enfin trouve ça bizarre
pourquoi moi je sais pas enfin montady
pourquoi elles m'ont dit que c'était
ridicule que ce site ait jamais vu c'est
pour ça qu'elle est les gens ici vos
connaissances vous
un bond à s'attaquer à une autre
critique et ils viennent vous voir
oui oui vous encourage oui oui comment
êtes-vous en dehors du football qu'est
ce qui vous intéresse
au moins on peut tout je m'intéresse aux
autres sports je viens danser
j'aime bien m'amuser je suis majorettes
alors je défile avec les majorettes de
foutoir enfin je suis plein de trucs
comme les autres aux filles bien et bien
je vous souhaite d'arbitré ma fois
encore longtemps et bien et de réussir
votre examen pratique puisque vous avez
réussi seulement l'examen théorique pour
l'instant c'est merci
[Musique]